which is right you know you ever have an
argument with somebody like let's just
call i don't want to [ __ ] text you
because
you know that [ __ ] don't go anywhere
yeah like it's my thumbs are tired
yeah yeah like bro you wrote a paragraph
i'm not reading that [ __ ] [ __ ] come
on get on call
okay here's a question for you have you
ever have you guys ever had like
the comments or like a comment on your
youtube or like some someone saying
something on twitter
that you know you can [ __ ] destroy
them slam dunk them in an argument
but it's it's equally as annoying
because you want to and you know you can
yeah but
there's too many of these types of
comments to like address them all oh
yeah yeah
if you say if you if you dress one then
you start just opening like pandora's
box
i've done that i've i've been on both
sides of that just being like
okay i see this dumbass comment i'm just
like okay i can't say anything
it's a lot of i know like i control
yourself like zen
zen mine right now with this like don't
get tilted yeah just keep it in yourself
like at least like go to your irl
friends and [ __ ] about it
like they all and then sometimes i just
look at them like
nah this kid is small brain as [ __ ] i
gotta put him in his position and i just
retweet i quote retweet being like look
at this clown
oh i i feel like the amount of restraint
it takes is like just stopping your piss
midstream
it's like the bottle's getting full
don't let it overflow
okay i don't need this i don't need this
yeah i'm okay like i don't need to
engage with this like
you're a [ __ ] idiot it's like the
first day of going vegetarian you go to
like a steakhouse right it's like
no i could do this i could do this
please i just like sometimes if they
come and sing damn i'll just i'll give
them a heart i'm like i want everyone to
see how stupid you are
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna engage it
but i'm gonna push this to the top just
so everyone can see how stupid
and it's like that one out of million
times when you do
acknowledge it or reply it's always
there they're always like they're
ready they're ready they're ready no
they're always like the surprise pikachu
like they're like ah i can't believe he
saw my comment what
i was talking [ __ ] and he replied to me
it's like what that only applies on
twitter though it's like how many
situations can you go in irl where you
absolutely slam dunk someone and then
they reply with a pog face
did you see that he just completely
talked me i'm so happy which is which is
i don't know i i i understand the
mentality where if you say something on
twitter
or on social media to like a big creator
or
platform like you you don't expect them
to ever see it but
i think you'd be surprised about how
many comments that we do actually end up
seeing
uh most of them we just you know we just
keep scrolling but we some of the
comments do actually stick out to us
especially
especially the ones where are like it's
like really
criticizing or really grating or one of
those ones i
had the thing that happened maybe like a
few months ago and it was the first time
this
ever happened to me and this one annoyed
me more than anything
like they weren't [ __ ] on me they
were [ __ ] on me
but it was someone else tweeting about
how they really enjoyed one of my videos
and
then someone was [ __ ] on them for
enjoying my video for some reason that
really pissed me off yeah it's like bro
you can [ __ ] on me but like yeah why you
got a [ __ ] on someone else for enjoying
it yeah
right like what's wrong with you man and
yeah that was just a mess so did you
reply to that i replied being like yo
dude i mean
it's cool if you don't like me but why
why are you gonna show them someone else
yeah yeah yeah
just leave them alone yeah yeah and then
they were they just kept like
antagonizing and i was just like
[ __ ] i'm not doing this i think the
one comments that's
like still angers me to this day i
realize we've talked about a lot of hate
comments
we're very tilted man as you can see no
because it's it's the comments that uh
stick out to us right but yeah i think
the one
the one that sticks out to me the most
and i probably won't ever forget
is um is when i uh when i got engaged uh
when i propose to sydney
like i don't really talk about my
personal life too much my twitter
because i like to keep that separate
from like me talking about anime but it
was like the one
one of the few times that i actually let
out my personal life
to the public yeah just because i wanted
to show the entire [ __ ]
very important time very happy how happy
i was right
and and how how this was one of the most
happiest moments of
my life and i wanted to share that of
course and i remember i met like
me and sydney are very close i'm i'm
glad that i can make jokes with sydney
in like some of like the most crucial
moments in my life
and like when i proposed i was like man
you're my wife but uh i still gonna have
my waifu send your car still my number
one
i know it's just like that was just a
funny joke yeah of course like that's
just the kind of relationship i have i'm
glad i'm with someone who i can joke
around with like that
yeah but and so sydney placed that joke
and somebody
like quotes they didn't even like quote
retweets that one
they just they screenshotted it right
right oh that's the worst
yeah they it's like at least give me
like some [ __ ] credit
yeah exactly they think they think
they're not gonna they think you can't
[ __ ] see it if they screenshot it
yeah because there's nothing that that
leads it back to them yeah yeah but they
screenshotted it and
they posted on their personal twitter
and was like woman
you should have better standards for
your men don't let your man get away
with this kind of [ __ ]
and i'm like you know nothing about my
relationship with sydney
that's right that is the biggest i know
more about your life than you yeah like
quite common right
like they they would they were judging
me because i was making this joke which
some some girls won't be happy with and
you know if you're not happy with that
kind of joke that's
that's completely different with that
kind of person yeah really simple right
exactly i i was with someone i could
trust to make that joke
but then sydney actually like commented
on it like
she quite retailed it and commented on
that and the reaction they made was just
such a like i don't like why you like
this you know what i mean
because they because when when she
replied when she applied she was like
i can't believe they've actually outed
me like they've just sent all their
followers to
me i'm like getting cyberbullied right
now and you're like what do you expect
if you should
if you talk [ __ ] online and you can't
take it back like how do you think we
for you
i love people who do that because it's
always it's usually like
young guys or girls like in their teens
obviously right yeah
and they just expect like how do they
not understand the concept of
if you're prepared to give [ __ ] you
better be prepared to take it yeah
exactly
it's like it's like you're you're
talking [ __ ] about someone yeah
do you expect them to just not fight
yeah like why are you acting like the
victim here yeah like where
where you're here judging my personal
life there are more followers than me
i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] dude like
you [ __ ] talk me i'ma [ __ ] smack you
right back
you better be prepared for that and if
you're not then don't say it in the
first place
leave it keep it to yourself if you're
going to smack talk and then you're
going to cry about being called out
yeah that's that's the equivalent of
like you going up to someone smacking
them in the face yeah then they smack
you back and you start crying
it's like you smacked me first i should
be the one crying not you what are you
crying about
so yeah basically if how to act on the
internet it's just like don't act the
way
don't act any differently than you would
in real life just be real life
yeah not that you guys needed to know
that because you're trash tasteless yeah
yeah i like the best taste
exactly rule number one just don't be a
[ __ ] right
it's really simple don't act like subaru
from re-zero
you should be fine oh my god wait what
do you mean
wait what'd you read dude in season one
he was an [ __ ] man
i mean was he though dude when he like
confessed
in front of like the whole uh like grand
court
yeah she told him not to i was like what
are you doing man i told you not i mean
i
i wouldn't call your time to shine i
wouldn't call him an [ __ ] as much as
i would just call him a clown
he was like no i think he was an [ __ ]
you do yeah i thought he wasn't
i mean either way it's not very good
right yeah i know you're either a clown
or an [ __ ]
either way he wasn't doing himself any
favors yeah but season two he looks like
he's turned himself around
don't be like season one subaru is what
we're saying right yeah yeah exactly
season two i've been very much enjoying
his character development yeah i'm glad
that he's
finally learning not to be an intel
should think of women as not an idol
yeah